I'm Julia
barabash
and I okay I'm from originally from
Ukraine and right now I'm working as
Cloud engineer and North cloud and
basically my scope is backend
development also I have experience with
different database Technologies and also
I have uh knowledge with AWS
certificates however the first my stop
was in Pasa Pasa is very nice city where
you can meet a lot of students it's a
big city uh with not a lot of apartments
and when I came as a student it was very
hard to find something uh to live and
find apartment and that time I realized
that wow we are not
spiders and we have some
problems for example people cannot live
on the streets a spider we cannot build
a nest on the tree and just live there
also we cannot get in somebody house
especially if you big spider you can
just get inside and claim it's your
house in my case it will work perfectly
I'm very afraid of spiders and also I we
cannot leave a tent so I cannot just put
a tent next to my university and live
there that's why we need to find
apartment and to for for finding an
apartment at that time I thought hm I
have some questions for
example uh is there possibility how I
can track a Partners posting is there a
way how I can R uh how I can track back
run uh price per City area and check
what is the price depends on the city
area in some City areas price can be
cheaper
additionally depends of the seasons you
also can find cheaper apartment for
example if there's not so much New
Commerce you can find something
easier and that point of time okay now I
have these questions I need something
that can help me to answer it and that
moment I real realizers exist some stuff
such as web
scrapping and basically web scrapping is
used for ex extracting data from
websites for example you can have the
you can have the sof soft then can
collect information that process
information there also you can do some
automation like to schedule your uh
collection of data and right now is very
important especially when we have a lot
of different machine learning stuff
around us and where you need to tr your
models and also some businesses as well
Define their decisions based on the data
on the trends the uh clients what they
want and what they buy at certain time
of point of time so data right now is
very important but is there possibility
to track and collect this by using
Python and we have magical Library and
this Library called Scrappy Scrappy is
basically tool used for tracking data
for website you can imagine it's simple
tools that can give you capability to
extract data collect data St store data
clean up your data it give you already
some predefined
Foundation usually with which one uh you
can build simple application and during
our session we will learn how to do this
by end of this session you will know how
you can do
this so what are the advantages of
scrapping the first thing with the
scrappy is has a synchronous
architecture it means that you send
request and you do not wait on the
response you you your application will
react on response by this it means that
it don't wait on the response because
some website implement this
functionality that they can recognize
web scrapping tools and do not send
response back to consume resources of
application and
basically fail collection of the data
and by reacting of the event you can
avoid this situation another wi uh with
scrap is there's a lot of
stuff for example for buil-in stuffff
for cleaning your data for selection of
your date for selection elements for
HTML code for example here you can have
two types of selector is basically
expess and CSS selector expess basically
you specify the way how you want to
Traverse your httm httl code to extract
specific elements and each it has the
same mechanism as CSA CSS selectors has
the same mechanism as CSS style where it
should match elements of the HTM HTML
page to give them style and by hidden
mechanism it extract all information
what we need and pass it except this it
also have possibility to export output
Json uh XML is CSS code is we need and
formatt it properly additionally it can
store
your data to est3 bucket Google Cloud
storage and also local file storage uh
by this also very powerful because you
can Implement your implementation send
this to S3 bucket and on S3 bucket you
can react some Lambda that will act on
your uh that will act on your file and
basically produce some events you can
get notification great uh
so let's talk additionally about
middleware it's one of the possible
powerful feature as well of the scrappy
because basically you can Define
additional code that can be executed
like hooks before sending requests
before receiving uh response before
sending data to the spider after uh
receiving output for the spider and by
this you can cover some use cases for
example add HTP notification add
additional headers that uh also retri
fail
request additionally in case you want to
filter out unsuccessful responses or
also filter out request that it's not
responses and that were not from your
target
domain and by this you will have already
some bunch of functionality that you can
use and collect your data so how we can
do this we can do this by basically in
three different steps the first step is
initialize our setup also project
architecture we will talk we will cover
this after that we will talk how we can
create simple parsing and then we talk
how we can also process this in
pipeline great let's talk first of all
how we can set up our scrap we can set
up our Scrappy by Simple Run pip install
scrap and after that on your local
machine you will be have additional
common line interface where you can
execute following commands for example F
page and on the com terminal you will
able also to extract some data from the
page also you can create uh project and
Spider by execution start start project
and gen spiders that we will use later
to create also some application and view
if you want to open your page that
you're rendering from website in browser
and see how Scrapy see it as well it can
be useful hold the Bing so so let's
start by uh creation of our project
so I want to do step by step so you will
learn as well we will learn uh
together and we will
clear our terminal and we will execute
the First Command where we just create
our project great we create our project
we open our folder and we already see
that we have some we have already some
um folder where we can have we already
have files and let's go back and let's
see what kind of files we have we have
magical uh we have
magical um structure where we already
have defined middle Wares custom
middleware you can enrich it will be
executed we can Define our pipelines or
also we can Define our settings for our
SP spider right and here F the spiders
where we keep all our SP
spiders and in additionally in items we
can Define the structure of the fem and
the pipelines we will Define the pipon
that we also be you I will show you
later you where you can basically clean
up your data process your data validate
your data and store your data great now
it's time to create our spider and for
creation of the spider we will use this
command uh it's called Uh Scrappy J
Spider where you basically
specify Scrappy command name of the SP
name of the spider and basically your
domain but what this command is doing so
basically what this
command
uh
it will destroy
um sorry for
disturbing one minute I have some
technical problem
sorry you're still with us we just your
screen so uh sorry for this I have some
problem problem with monitor it will was
disconnected but let's continue
so I hope you still can hear me and uh
let's say share my screen again yeah we
can still we can still hear
you
um so uh okay now you can see I am back
and you can see my screen again so what
it will do basically it will basically
what we'll do we first of all execute
this command after that we Define it
will create spider with defined template
that we go also will go through that we
Define our URL we Define the method that
we use for parsing and at the end we
just simple execute
our we just simple execute our uh Spider
great
so let's do
this so let's execute Scrappy gu spider
to uh get our spider after that but
before this we need to go to the uh
right folder it's
called Uh
apartment
um
we are in the right folder and let's
execute okay here we have our spider so
it understands the scrappy framework
understands we need to put the our
spider in the correct folder where we
have all spiders also it creates some
Base Class and the base class it means
just do inheritance from the spider
where inside the spider it already has
set up that will send request to the
URL and to URL and pass response here to
speit up our demo and also
implementation we already go here and we
copy this implementation that I already
implemented just pass it and I will
explain so basically here we specify the
unique name of our spider after that we
specify domain from which the way we
want to get responses at the end we will
start EX execution we will start our uh
specify our start Ur that we want to
execute and here we have our parer and
basically our parer will pass our HTML
it means it will gets list of all
elements that we want to pass and here
we want to pass this page so basically
our URL page that we want to
pass this will be our URL page and we
want to pass all these diff because all
these diffs contains our information and
we can see that each of these
diffs for example this one can be
identifi uniquely by
class State item
great and here if we can go back we can
see that we Define class that contains
this
value and and we will pass all the gifts
after this we want to extract also name
price size rooms for this we also need
to go and identify how we can this use
it for example name contained in as a
element
H2 price is can be located by attributes
data test with no price array in room we
specify this that these elements have
this attributes with name price area in
rooms Scrappy will understand extract
this information and save it as
jome after that we understand that we
want to get all information and for this
we need already have some understanding
how it
works if we
go if you go uh here to this page you
can explore you can check explore URL
page you can see
that here we have page and usually if
you increment for example two you will
go to the next one if again you will go
to the next
one and here we need to implement it so
we get the current URL we extract the
number here increment the number we
already have our URL template and
basically here our URL template and
basically here we just increment our
page
number and we do our
execution and when we do our
execution we will save it to Jon so
let's let's let's do this one of these
commands should have this so let's start
do execution of our
spite um
so it's stop
usually okay I for so we can see here we
have 4003 it's because of the page
doesn't allow our to get response for
this as I mentioned is the settings we
have some some settings that we want to
set up for our request and one of the
settings we can specify our user agent
and by specifying user agent we will uh
be able to get our request so let's go
here and put in the
settings the value that we need our user
agent and let's execute
again so right now you see that we do
execution we get our data and also we
get response so we get our 200 it's a
bit slow I believe it because right now
I'm sharing my screen that's why
internet is a bit slower but usually
it's
faster and if we already see we have our
data here and we go to our apartment
data and we can see that we have our
information we have name we have price
we have size and we have rooms great we
already Sav some information it's very
easy
but in case we want to do something more
and we want to have pipelines with
pipelines what we can do basically we
can process our
information we can process our
information we can enrich our
information we can clean up our
information and also we Define St can
store the storage and what of the files
where we can do this basically in the
this uh file where is pipelines Scrappy
framework already defined for us foral
class apartment pipeline where from each
item we will each item will pass to this
method and this method will process our
information let's again copy our code
from here where I already defined
everything so we can simply
execute let's go uh through this code so
basically uh here we collect uh we
extract the
price additionally what we do after that
we extract the size we extract number of
the rooms also we extract after that we
do calculation price per met squares and
we return this item after return this
item we will send this to
our to our output let's check if it's
finished so meanwhile the old
implementation is finished and we can
also have some data that we will talk
about later but let's try to execute
with our
pipeline great we don't have any errors
we have 200s and let's go back it's also
contains like some old data but what I
did and I forget to do I forget to
enable pipeline so in Middle where
settings you need to enable your
pipeline and for this for enabling
custom pipeline what you need to do
let's search for
pipeline uh pipeline
here here we just uncomment it and we
enable after that our pipeline will be
enabled and then we can execute
again okay let's clean
and let's start execution
again okay we have our results okay we
already can see that we already have
name we already have
the uh name of the apartment we already
clean up our price we already clean up
our size we already room and also price
per uh met squar
and we if we go to
our we load here it's basically a pens
some data just to be uh so so you can
Deb back but here you can see that we
already have our data so we have price
size room and price per squ met
squares and this with simple
implementation we can pass our
information also after execution you you
can have some metadata for example you
can see uh the number of
response how long it takes also uh how
many response was done you also have
some metadata that you can use for
later and if you s up what's the
benefits of Scrappy is basically it's
very powerful framework with which you
can basically scrap scrap collect data
from uh web also it use a synchronous
architecture it has also items where you
can you can structure all the
information that you need to use it has
also selectors with exp pass selector in
CSS selector where with this selectors
you can easily extract elements and
process it and also a lot of different
uh
outputs and it's from all from my side
and thank you for your attention
questions and let's check your
questions let's
check I think uh there's no difference
let's I show you on the page so can we
use uh vscot or jet brain is prefer with
this application I believe there's
there's no difference so you can use
both if you want is basically you should
be sure that your python environment
works and also your Ry you install this
application in your environment virtual
environment but I believe there's no
difference is there some other questions
that somebody wants to
ask yes uh also there's possibility to
run it daily uh to run it daily uh also
you can there are some application
there's also some application where you
do to scrapping on cloud you can check
this also I think there's integration
with po sqs where you at the end of the
your processing you can send save it to
database at the end uh so yeah it's
possible to do with this
Library as this uh as the scrapping best
practices like time of a day I
believe uh I'm not sure about this maybe
you can just run uh some analysis on
your internet how it works maybe in the
night will be easier
because
uh uh because
um because um there's not a lot of
traffic and there's not a lot of people
so maybe you can check also I see
there's a lot of different questions
from the same person for example would
it work at museums the devel when I work
in museums the developers would shut
down
scrapping uh they would protect their
website from scrapping or they would not
collect scrapping during the day can you
BL would shut down the site so they use
scrapping to shut down the site I think
is as you make if I understand correct
are to protect the
website yeah there are some stuff that
people use to protect the website but it
depends of the how they use it I think
there like it's just long discussion it
depends of the website
but with Scrappy you can for example
generate all this unique uh IPI address
so if your your page is checking the IP
address there's not a lot of requests
from the same IPI address with with
Scrappy you can Define proxies that can
be used in go around additionally with
uh Scrappy there's a lot of plugins that
you can use extensions where for example
it can also use selenium and play route
to grow to go around like JavaScript
Dynamic loading that's also before
getting the page it will do some
actions authentification so I'm not sure
um specific use case but in the
scrapping there's a lot of different sty
you can
check uh and check
around is there some specific use case
but authentification checking for ipis
and also different extension to get
around the loading with JavaScript it's
possible to do with scrapping
yep and yeah uh there some other
questions hi Juliet I think there's just
some comments that are in the chat about
your presentation but I don't really see
any more thank you for your attention
and for your comments I was very happy
to see you and also I was very happy to
be here thank you very
much thank you so much and um everybody
thank you for coming um and uh enjoy the
rest of the conference if there are no
other questions let me just check one
last
[Music]
time yeah I think ah I guess we have one
more question so I'll put that on
stage uh how you scale uh how you uh so
how do you scale architecture how volume
data set where a copyright
issue uh this is copyright issue I
cannot answer because it's connected to
the law so you need to ask like lawyer
Law Department M but with high volume
data set it's again it's possible to do
concurr concurrency processes you can U
and Scrappy it's possible to find uh to
define the number of concurrent requests
that you want to do and you want to send
and additionally as I mentioned is
always response on the events so
basically you can Define how many
requests you want to process response in
the same moment by by
um by settings so you can process uh
your results
concurrently also you can define a few
spiders adjust them around in parallel
and then Define different concurrency
processes so it's possible to to do this